[Music]
anybody here fly jet blue before i have
i love it it's probably the best airline
there is long beach jet blue other than
singapore yeah but for the united states
and they give you blue chips
potato chips you know i flew spirit it's
not that bad dude for 45 i actually just
flew spirit here it was kind of nice it
was not bad i i [ __ ] on them all the
time did you get those good ass tickets
to vegas for like 14 bucks yeah i got
him i didn't get it for 14. like 40
bucks right but it's like 47. i got it
for like 40 bucks and i sat next to jeff
mayweather you got to go to floyd
mayweather is that right yeah yeah crazy
didn't he play solitaire
i was i'm such a fan and i was nervous
the whole time because i used to watch
all his videos and stuff and he's
playing solitaire and i was like hey man
i'm like
big fan and he goes thanks and i was
like oh [ __ ] i ruined that
yeah i guess lloyd money mayweather he's
no no his uncle
his uncles yeah yeah flies but i think
he's having a strange relationship yeah
oh but i don't know do you think he is
you know poor people thing do you think
he had an empty duffel bag
you know what
he did he did have a duffel bag on him
that looked a little suspicious dude it
was part cardboard
there was nothing in it yeah he [ __ ]
up that relationship so there's a jet
blue pilot who was just pulled off of a
plane before takeoff after failing a
breathalyzer
oh [ __ ]
yeah for that
i mean that's okay
anybody having to uh be illegal it's
mostly autopilot the legal b.a.c
or a pilot oh for a pilot no all right
go ahead what's the normie bac 2.08 0.08
for a pilot it's .04
oh oh
that's like half a beer man but do you
think mid-flight they get drunk and then
they sober up by the time they get down
so they're like before they fly they're
sober right and then they go up and they
pull out the whiskey
or choice of drink you know like
autopilot [ __ ]
and then by the time they get down they
sober up and then they wake up i feel
like we've had a lot of drunk pilots on
flights that we just learned denzel
denzel we've talked about him here
exclusively too drunk pilots just pilots
in general yeah the whole cockpit wait
is this like a common thing dude you've
never seen flight they pilot i drink the
vodkas
i drink the vodkas
no i've seen i mean do they even work
because pilots are the plane does all
the work i know it's like a tesla right
there's a pallet one two three
[ __ ]
there's a plane so this jetblue pilot
was pulled off of a plane in buffalo new
york after allegedly blowing four times
the legal limit for pilots on a
breathalyzer test according to four
times that's crazy
[Laughter]
was it happy hour yeah for sure wait
tell me what's happening the
breathalyzer before they take off yeah
every time whoa
that's that's what i believe when i had
a dui
i think you have to blow up breathalyzer
all pilots
like that's like protocol give a story
that would be a reasonable protocol
well no i'm just saying because um
i was in a plane recently uh uh uh a kid
took me up
literally a kid yeah he just learned how
to play
yes he's like holy [ __ ] he's 12 years
old yeah
he's a kid to me he's like 20. but like
he he uh he took me on a plane didn't
use a breathalyzer he could have been
drunk obviously i was pregnant like
balls dude
it's a propeller plane yeah
it was fun maybe commercial flights have
a different role
for sure
because corporate but i saw them work
though he barely works he goes echo echo
five five four four three two two four
four echo nine or nine oh [ __ ] in
front of you to look cool yeah and then
they have a like [ __ ] face
live action
they have an ipad that just basically
like a gps that tells them to stay on
the course and then he just the [ __ ]
using [ __ ] google maps to get there
dude
i did the same [ __ ] in costa rica
there's the same [ __ ] in front of me
like clipboard like reference i'm like
yeah whatever it's not really it's not
[ __ ] real echo five five fly four
yeah that's what they say and chicken
clearance for uh some [ __ ] probably
that's a [ __ ] probably
did he end with hike
so this 52 year old pilot blew a .17 on
a breathalyzer test
that's obviously over the legal limit
for pilots which is a did they say a
choice of drink
tequila oh yeah yeah i was talking about
it
if your point is if you're 1.7 are you
kind of like obviously it depends on the
person
0.1.1.17 yeah are you pretty [ __ ]
sloppy at that point i i can tell you
from experience um when i got my dui i
was almost that and i was pretty toasty
man
yeah
what were you driving what kind of big
what kind of big-ass vehicle were you
driving yeah semi truck
here's why i didn't deserve it though
because i got it
at uci after uh like a frat party you
know when you you totally deserved it
already dude but you were just driving
like a tiny distance i remember yes so i
remember like taking a patron shot as we
were leaving and so that's what really
that's it
no no i was drinking the whole thing
but like as we were leaving to get on
the bus 0.17 what yeah
no no no to get bro your organs are
failing yeah
no to get yeah i only have like a pint
of blood in me
to get on the bus one of those guys one
of those guys the bus took us to the
parking lot and so we get we get there
and then a couple of my friends were
like oh we're hungry i was like oh [ __ ]
i'm hungry too but back then the only
thing that was open was del taco
drive-through
that's an hour ago jack wasn't there yet
drive-through
only
and
and it was like two blocks maybe i don't
feel it man it's like two blocks maybe
and it's mostly parking lot that you're
driving through yeah it's mostly parking
lot so i pulled out of the parking lot
and immediately just
and then they
they made me do the whole test and
everything but here's you went through
the drive through backwards you realize
that right
but worst of all their tackles got soggy
this is an ethanol we never got to the
tacos
the worst part what's camping on you man
dude i was gonna get those chili cheese
fries
all of it got soggy i i was gonna get it
i didn't never got to it wait you didn't
get to you didn't get the food irvine we
never i just pulled out of the parking
lot of all of the
in the area
and pd runs a tight ship they do nothing
i got pulled over by irvine pd right and
then we got sat on the curb because they
like to do that to asians and then the
cop walked up to me he was a chinese cop
and he said
you ever have any priors and i was like
oh yeah
because i was a juvenile oh yeah
you have to tell me
yeah and he goes what for rape
murder and i'm like
why
why would i be on the streets i'm 16.
why there like why can't you start with
something like that be a priority it
would be a durian yeah the first thing
he went to was
rape
he said it like that too like a matter
of fact like i know you're one of those
[ __ ] murderer rapers bomb making is
it like tony the tiger yeah it was rape
[Laughter]
and i was like all right we would love
for frosty to face the sponsorship
please my favorite cereal and the funny
thing is you know when irvine pd pulls
you over they don't pull you over with
one car they call 10 of their [ __ ]
squad cars out they do
when officers come out for skinny 14
year old asian boy sat sat on the curb
right
but you were bald so that's i was bald
soul is my bragger he's so skinny
my friend had car parts because he
hadn't finished his car so they're
looking in the back they're like are
those stolen i better not see any
scratch [ __ ] serial numbers or
whatever whatever and i was like trying
to tell them oh yeah i got busted for
graffiti but then he just kept going
down this laundry list of like assault
battery like i was like he's not even
using evidence
of [ __ ] cops graffiti rape i know
i was just like oh i was caught tagging
grapefeeding like dude
irvine cops are the [ __ ] worst and
that's probably why it's the safest city
in america embezzling mass murdering
better not be laser tagging i'll tell
you
if you're laying there right now you're
going right away
moon landing denying
it's like all these different that was i
can't do that yeah can i do it
you know i actually got pulled up for a
cussing
for driving under the influence as well
in irvine one time and it was the only
time i've ever been pulled over for uh
being under the influence and i was
totally under the influence i'm not
gonna lie i maybe almost deserved dui
but i didn't deserve them because i
passed the test oh and uh they in the
[ __ ] way to tell a story
the funny thing is so far
what's the most [ __ ] story
it was after a halloween party so i was
in a akuma outfit
oh cool
i was a kuma do you have pictures i want
to see you as a cool really cold because
if you don't know kuma he doesn't wear a
lot of clothes you know what i mean and
i'm not exactly actually buff or
anything like that so it was like you
know you need that big necklace yeah
yeah the big b
you know
and uh and i was sleepy it was like 4
a.m i was sleepy after this party so i
was i was veering off the road and
somebody called the cops on me so cuz
you're wobbly driving ass citizen or
whatever he's probably in bison it's
stupid
gestapo
cops pulled me over they administered a
drug test on me i like have to summon
all of my dance training and balance and
stuff like that in order to figure out
how to pass the test i passed the test
even though i maybe barely and i got
some tests what choreography did you
have to do all the breath [ __ ] right
walk in the line of stuff yeah in an
akuma outfit
and then he sits me down and the very
last thing they do
is asking me he's like do you want to
take a breathalyzer test
right and then if you don't take a
breathalyzer test they can take you yeah
if you do take a breathalyzer test then
obviously if you pass it then you're
good to go and that was obviously i had
learned from some friends at that time
so i was like [ __ ] it i'm gonna [ __ ]
go for it because i don't want to get
cuffed right now if this guy just
doesn't believe me
i take the breathalyzer chest and then
he still has to [ __ ] play me in that
moment and he's like do you know what
the legal drinking limit
and i was like 0.08
and then he's like do you know what you
got i'm like no i i don't you have the
reading guy
yeah and then he goes you got .04 and
i'm like alright cool and i'm good and
then he let me go but realistically
like cops will do especially in irvine
they will do whatever to make sure
you're taking because they're also the
cops that pick up homeless people and
drop them off in santa ana you know
especially that one lady by
jack-in-the-box you know i'm talking
about the homeless lady who always shows
the specific lady she's always there
she's always at the jaguar oh jumbo jack
jane yeah
quick mama look at quick draw over there
this guy's quick joe ryan this guy's
really good he actually knows that he
probably built a community
doing all those tests in the beginning
helped sober you up
you're just like a [ __ ] whack ass
honestly you're scared when you do it
dude oh you know what i was i was drunk
enough that i wasn't scared at all
when i did those [ __ ] when i did
those tests i was like i'm [ __ ]
crushing it right you weren't getting
all but you got the dui right look like
you're passing you're different dude
i know for sure i passed those because
oh the balance one yeah i did i did dude
i felt like a dancer that time dude i
was like i'm [ __ ] killing it and then
afterwards he was like well this guy
still sounds drunk i think he's like so
he's like
do you want the breathalyzer and i was
like
no
and then
however and then
and then he's like all right he starts
cuffing me right here's the reason why i
took the breathalyzer test
and then and then i immediately but then
i immediately was like wait what
like like all my confidence just went
away
a true drunk like a true drum yeah and i
was like wait no okay i'll do it you
know it's like it's too late now yeah
and the idea of you being drunk doing
balance thing and the cop going dude
this drunk guy's killing it
he's like hey
[Music]
i can't be pissed he's like it's
confident [ __ ]
this guy's too good it's going down
eventually his confidence is a .09
but but then i blew that [ __ ] way too
high
damn did you go
passed out
just blew me i realized you were so
confident that you weren't like hell
yeah with the breathalyzer plug it into
my lungs
i'm a fart in that thing
was your life pretty [ __ ] after that
like with all the inconveniences of
having a dui for a little bit a good
year of annoying [ __ ] yeah it gets
pretty like a lot of money and like uh
uh i ended up like getting a lawyer to
just like do it quick
um but it costs it cost like a couple
thousand dollars out at the end of it
how was a a
uh i eat any hot girls
spoken like a true drunk
did you get married
yeah we had an aaa wedding uh it's kind
of boring good dry yeah um
now i went to one meeting oh you only
had to go to one well no i had to go to
like six but i just like scribbled in
sent test and replaced it
that's great
well all it is is you have a card and
then they like someone signs it and so i
it's a signature and so i went to five
different friends and i was like here
sign this with your handwriting sign
this with your handwriting and then yeah
well done those meetings are sad as [ __ ]
man there's so it makes you want to
drink right yeah dude
yeah yeah that's real [ __ ] because i'm
just like uh an idiot kid that was
trying to go to del taco these people
are like i [ __ ] ruined my three kids
lives and you're like oh [ __ ] i drove
facebook into a train
i'm the only survivor
i have seven children i had seven
children
i don't anymore because i drove into a
train at first
first he did it i saw it
she's too real for me i'm just trying to
go to [ __ ] psychology class and [ __ ]
i don't know there's too much del taco
[Music]